Alr
ça part
donc
on a la musique donc un are vidéo sur l'
donc n'cè pas ta productivité elle
accélère ta confusion donc pourquoi la
vraie compétence de 2026 n'est pas un
promte mais comment la cultiver donc
comment cultiver l ça qu'on va voir dans
cette vidéo là donc ça part donc le
paradoxe tout le monde utilise Et
pourtant tu es encore perdu. Donc tu as
plus d'outils, tu as plus de vitesse, tu
as plus de contenu à générer mais tu as
pas plus de clarté, tu as pas plus de
direction. Donc là, tu commences à être
perdu. sont dans un un cerc vicieux de
tu sais pas quoi faire, il y a trop
d'options. Donc l'illusion d'être occupé
donc ça te mène à tuas l'illusion de tu
te fais submerger par plein de
possibilités puis
tu te sens occupé mais tu avances pas.
Tu es tout le temps en train d'avancer
parci par là par là. Non non non. Puis
finalement tu avances pas nulle part. Il
y a pas une direction tu t'envas tu suis
cette direction là c'est comme tout le
temps passe par là plein s submergé.
Donc ça du l'insécurity work du
mouvement sa avancement réel. Ça faut
faire très attention 2026 donc demander
10 idées à à générer un plan en 2
minutes. Changer de niche le lendemain
puis tu recommences depuis le début.
Donc tout le temps là j'ai une nouvelle
idée ça fait un plan tout part. OK le
lendemain c'est terminé. OK ben ok bon
next. Puis là, il y a plein d'idées tout
le temps. Puis là, tu vois, tu les
coules tout le temps en mode tu sais la,
c'est comme dans Matrix, c'est comme la
la jeup rouge, la fille à jeup rouge, tu
es tout le temps attiré vers la fille à
jeupe, tu sais. C'est comme ça ça tu es
attiré vers l'objet brillant, tu sais.
Fait faut faire attention à ça avec
parce que c'est très facile de tirer
vers les nouveaux les les nouveaux s les
nouveaux euh euh les nouvelles I modèle
LLM, peu importe, les nouvelles
opportunités. Puis si tu es tout le
temps porté à aller vers les nouvelles
opportunités, ben tu vas jamais avancer
parce que tu vas tout le temps être
perdu. Tu dois mener te focus. Donc puis
le résultat concret, ça va faire que tu
vas avoir zéro, tu vas rien faire parce
que L a juste exécuté ta confusion très
efficacement même.
Puis c'est ça qu'il faut travailler,
c'est OK, est-ce que je m'envis dans la
bonne direction ? Est-ce que c'est le la
bonne chose pour moi ? Est-ce que ça
fait du sens pour moi d'aller dans cette
directionlà au lieu de tout le temps euh
il y a quoi ? Il y a quoi d'autre ? Tu
sais sinon tu te pas
là ce nom là je pas de le dire sixen me
la boy arraché qui parle de l'entropie
psychique donc sans direction consciente
l'esprit dérive vers la facilité la
distraction et l'impulsion donc ça c'est
si tu laisses les choses aller telles
qu'elles sont sans rien faire
naturellement
ça va être le désordre
Donc sans intention, ça va toujours
mener vers le chaos. Par exemple, même
chose. OK, on prendre un exemple de
tu sais pas ta chambre, tu pas laver ta
chambre, ta maison, ton appart pendant
une semaine. Ben si tu laisses tout ça
aller, ben dans une semaine, dans de
semaines, ça va être le chaot total. Il
va avoir de la bouffe partout, va avoir
ça va être tout dégueu. Tu sais,
même chose pour ton esprit. Si tu
médites pas, tu prends pas des moments
pour relaxer puis te concentrer sur
toi-même pour aller clean up un peu ton
mental, ton esprit, ben ça va être le
dawa. Ça va être ça va brosser bien trop
dans ta tête, tu vas penser à 10000
affaires puis ça va rouler constamment.
Donc faut aller mettre la structure dans
ta pensée, dans dans ta business, dans
ta chambre ou ta ton app d'aller. OK, on
va aller clean up puis mettre une
intention derrière. Donc l'entropie
c'est pensé dispersée, anxiété qui est
constante, désir contradictoire. Donc tu
all vers là mais finalement c'est vers
là tu vas aller. Finalement c moi
c'était pas faire ça que fallait que
j'aille finalement pu là je tu sais
réactif aux distractions. Tu vas être
hyper distrait par toutes les
possibilités
puis de quand c'est dans l'ordre
psychique c'est ton attention va être
dirigée. Objectif clair état de flow
possible intentionnel. Tout ce que tu
fais va être intentionnel. Puis c'est là
que tu vas aller plus vers la partie ici
qui est l'ordre. Ça va pas être le chaos
avec l'ordre parce que tu vas être tuas
une intention claire objectif précis
puis tu vas pouvoir aller dans un état
de flow que tu vas pouvoir travailler
là-dedans en deep work sans te laisser
distraire. C'est ça l'objectif.
Donc
attendez un peu. Lia ne réduit pas
l'entropie, elle la double.
Donc avant l' tu quelques distractions
tu sais
quelques points de car quelques options
de carrière tu peux policier tu peux
être enseignant tu peux être c tu peux
être ça quelques idées de business tu
pourrais faire une business de je sais
pas moi de chauffage une business de
même si ça reg encore plus tu peux faire
une business de d'aculture tu peux faire
une business de je sais pas de linge tu
sais c'est comme quelque chose un plan à
la fois alors il a là c'est accès
illimité à tout de suite. Tu peux faire
du ecom, tu peux faire euh du SEO, tu
peux faire euh peu importe business
physique, tu peux faire tout est
possible. Tu peux te faire tout. L
connaît tout, tu as les outils
nécessaires pour faire tout.
Puis ça fait des tuas des idées générées
en 30 secondes. Plein d'affaires
possible e en une journée, tu peux avoir
un plan d'affaires, tu peux avoir toutes
des stratégies, tu peux contacter tout
le monde, des investisseurs pour aller
là-dedans. Tu peux partir dans toutes
tes directions. Puis la direction, ben
il y en a pas.
Puis un prom, c'est juste une question.
Si tu sais pas ce que tu veux vraiment,
la meilleure Io au monde peut rien faire
pour toi. Donc c'est là que l'important
d'avoir une idée fixe, avoir une vision
claire de que tu t'en vas puis là va
t'aider. Mais si tuas aucune idée, tu es
perdu va juste amplifier le fait que tu
es perdu encore plus.
La vraie compétence de 2026 c'est pas
maîtriser les promir
ass de clarté sur toi-même pour lui
donner une direction.
C'est pas un problème technique, c'est
un problème de connaissance de soi.
C'est que tu sais pas c'est quoi toi tu
veux, c'est où ta valeur ajoutée, c'est
quoi tes valeurs, c'est quoi ta vision,
c'est quoi tes objectifs. Si tu sais pas
ça, L va amplifier ça puis tu vas faire
n'importe quoi encore plus que ce que tu
faisais avant.
Donc les deux modes cognitifs, tuas
hyper focus attention dirigée et intense
sur une tâche mode production exécution
livraison. Ça nécessite une recette qui
est claire. Ça c'est ce que a fait en
permanence.
Skater focus, c'est un esprit qui est
diffus, semiconscient. Les meilleures
idées émergent ici. Donc c'est quand ton
idée ton ton mental va être calmé
sur la douche en marchant, en méditant.
Puis moi je pour moi marcher méditer là
c'est ça qui g le plus d'idées au monde
parce que justement tu
ton esprit ton esprit
se calme puis là po
il a plein d'idées qui popent puis les
meilleures idées pop là parce que tu es
seul avec toi-même tu es focus dans le
moment présent c'est là que les idées
émergent
Méditer c'est une activité, c'est non,
excusez-moi, c'est activer le seul mode
cognitif que Lemplacera jamais. Fait
d'où l'importance de méditant 2026, ça
va avoir énormément de valeur pour les
idées que ça l'émerge.
Puis aussi un autre point important,
c'est de savoir pourquoi toi tu es là,
pourquoi toi tu es sur terre. Parce que
si tu sais pas pourquoi toi tu es sur
terre,
ben c'est ça comme je disais L va juste
te faire perdre encore plus la route
parce que tu sais pas où c'est que tu
t'en vas. Donc c'est là qui mène à un
autre point qui est important.
Donc ça c'est un concept que j'ai
connu dans des livres puis aussi à
l'école entrepreneurship de Bos qui
parlait de l'quil qui ta raison d'être
c'est c'est où tu veux aller c'est quoi
c'est quoi ta vision pourquoi tu es sur
terre
puis ça extrêmement important parce que
étant donné que toutes les possibilités
sont infinies sur terre ben l'important
c'est savoir c'est où que toi tu veux
aller pourquoi toi tu tu es sur terre
c'est où tu veux aller toi parce que là
tu as toutes les possibilités au mond
monde les procédures ont infinies.
Donc l'équig c'est quoi ? On va checker
ça rapidement là. Vous pouvez aller lire
un il y a un livre qui s'appelle juste
Ikig qui va expliquer vraiment plus le
concept en précisément mais relativement
simple mais qui t'amène des questions
complexes à te poser
dans l' c'est ta raison d'être se trouve
à l'intersection de quatre dimensions.
Puis l'a peut t'exécuter peut exécuter
dans n'importe quelqu choisir ta
direction c'est uniquement ton travail à
toi. C'est uniquement toi qui peux faire
ça.
Donc sans clarté sur qui tu es, t'amène
juste pour plus vite dans la mauvaise
direction. Là moins que Ah oui, parfait.
Je peux aller zoomer là-dessus. malade
W. OK, donc
l'intersection les cartes inter
l'intersection qu'on parlait c'est ici.
Donc là, il y a des noms qui vont pas
apparaître parce que là ça été fait avec
l' encore une fois parce qu'il manque
des parties mais bon pas grave. Donc
c'est l'intention de c'est quoi
ce pourquoi tu es doué naturellement ce
dont le monde a besoin,
ce pourquoi tu peux être payé pour faire
puis
l'intersection de tout ça c'est ton
équil
à ta place c'est là que tu tu crées le
plus de valeurs dans le monde autour de
toi et que tuaimes.
Mais ça trouver son équil
ça va bien beau comme ça de juste le
remplir mettre plein de stock moi ce que
j'ai fait je l'ai rempli je l'ai bourré
j'ai mis plein de stock mais dit si je
le remplis le plus possible ça va être
le plus précis possible mais non
au final ça l'équ tu le trouves en
faisant des choses en sortant de ta zone
de confort en essayant des choses en
apprenant des choses c'est là que tu vas
te rendre compte que oh ben en faisant
telle affaire, j'aime quand même ça en
faisant tel autre un peu moins ça.
Ça je fais ça mais c'est pas tant payant
que ça tu sais c'est j'aime ça mais
je peux pas gagner ma vie avec ça ou je
fais ça mais
le monde là ils ont pas besoin de ça
bien dans vie tu sais c'est juste du du
fla fla fait que on dirait que ça donne
pas de sens à ce que je fais c'est des
questions qui viennent en expérimentant
en apprenant des choses queé tu vas
trouver ton ok moi j'aime ça je peux
être payé à faire ça en plus Nice. Puis
ben que tu aimes ça, ben tu vas
peut-être commencer à développer des
skills là. Tu vas apprendre puis tu vas
devenir bon là-dedans en plus.
Puis ben tu te rends compte que le monde
sont prêt à payer quand même pour ça.
Donc tu le monde on il en ont besoin.
C'est pas juste un il y a pas de valeur
flou tu sais. C'est comme vraiment tu
crées de la valeur dans le monde dans la
vie des gens les entreprises autour de
toi. Donc c'est là tu trouver ton mais
ça ça vient avec un travail
d'expérimentation de plein de choses
dans ta vie. Donc ça l'arrive pas comme
ça.
Mais une belle quête de vie à trouver,
c'est trouver ton équipe.
Euh puis l'action concrète, fais juste
10 minutes de méditation. Essaie de
faire 10 minutes de méditation. Fais
juste, tu te poses,
tu te concentres sur ta respiration.
Je pense le plus simple, c'est ça.
C'est simple mais hyper tough.
Sincèrement, c'est vraiment t mais
tout le monde est de le faire. Ça suffit
juste de faire du travail, la
persévérance puis du travail acharné de
continuer même si c'est donc tu fais 10
minutes de méditation. Le plus simple,
je pense que c'est juste de tu te
concentres sur ta respiration fait juste
par la zone de ton nez, c'est juste de
sentir un peu l'air qui rentre dans ton
nez, l'air qui sort de ton nez et cetera
comme ça. Juste l'air rentre,
l'air sort puis tu tes yeux mais tu
essayes d'observer ça de observer les
sensations
puis ça ce que ça va faire c'est juste
que tu vas calmer ton esprit. Tu vas le
focuser sur une chose qui est tangible.
tes sensations corporelles, ça va calmer
ton esprit.
Donc
ça ça va quand ton esprit
puis là les idées puis il vont pas
mais là c'est 10 minutes mais c'est vous
comprenez c'est pas 10 minutes une fois
parce que ça va rien faire mais si tu
fais 10 minutes le matin le soir puis tu
ess de faire ça chaque jour demandé tu
vas faire il m' faire un 20 minutes un
30 minutes un 1 heur oh là là tu des
idées qui v pas ma là
Puis essaie de le faire le matin avant
d'ouvrir le chat GPT.
Mais un 10 minutes juste pour clarifier
c'est quoi ton intention, c'est quoi tu
veux faire
puis la clarté précède le prompt. Donc
si trouvez ça utile follow, ça me fait
plaisir. Sincèement euh là je commence
je commence à faire des vidéos, je
commence à aimer aussi les vidéos que
que je fais. Je trouve ça cool, je
trouve ça intéressant. Je sais pas pour
moi le fait de verbaliser ce que
j'apprends,
ben je je l'apprends de plus en plus, je
l'imprègne de plus en plus sur moi parce
que je dois la verbaliser. Donc c'est
plus je dois vraiment l'implémenter en
de moi. Fait que moi je trouve ça cool.
Je sais pas vous autres, je continue à
en faire. fait que écoutez si vous avez
trouvé de la valeur là-dedans minimum je
sais pas vous êtes rendu à 14 minutes.
Je vois dans les je voir un peu les
stats. Il y en a qui c'est genre après
20 secondes, il y a plein de monde qui
ont kiffé leur camp sont partis.
Écoutez, je comprend début je vais
essayer de rendre le plus dynamique
possible pour que le monde ess de rester
un minimum puis
donc
journée. Co?